so mr. secretary it's great great to
have you on ski talk
I always thought the military should you
know we had a you know once airplanes
became important the Air Force was
invented but now we have space why isn't
there a space for so there is a space
force there is there under the Air Force
there is under the Air Force but you
know the army and the Navy and the
intelligence community also build
operate satellites many of them were as
big as a school bus mm-hmm
one called the Hubble Space Telescope Oh
an excellent cousins well we have
cousins of that that point downward
exactly and but they're really big
they're not a wave to them actually
every now and then we know that's true
for you good for you we'll say hi back
so so I I'd like to wave two satellites
in case they looking at me can I believe
for real that they can resolve the
fingers in my hand as I wave
not quite yet but you never know where
technology is heading what do you mean
you never know no that was not an answer
but you know what do you may not be able
to tell you okay then he has to kill it
because you watch any Hollywood movie
this satellite is you know first as
fuzzy said enhance and it's we know is
all BS but enhance the photo that's low
resolution you can't just say enhance
and have some algorithm show detail
where there wasn't detail there before
unless you invented it to put it in
there that's all bs
the the technology that that the United
States military and many other
militaries have is is amazing and can do
amazing things and you you can get great
resolution from space looking at things
happening on the earth but you know you
you're gonna have to wave for a while
before the you know contempt you know
contemporary technology is gonna be able
to pick that up
Plus while I'm waving there has to be a
satellite right there who's looking at
me right and and unless there's
geosynchronous satellite it's got to
like be passing over for that
to happen coverage is one of the biggest
issues with satellites is and in the
movies a satellite is always available
on demand exactly when you need it to
look at the bad guy in reality it
sometimes can take some time sort of
like in the movie the Martian when
they're trying to get the the satellites
in position to see where Matt Damon's
character is so that was intelligently
written in that regard absolutely right
[Music]